what are the powers of mecca godzilla
and how would it defeat godzilla or kong
by using them
here in this video we shall take a deep
look into what makes this mechanical
kaiju
one of the most dangerous opponents that
godzilla has ever faced
in the past and will face again here in
the future
in most of us in godzilla vs kong in his
debut appearance mecca godzilla is
depicted as an extraterrestrial villain
that confronts godzilla in subsequent
iterations mechagodzilla is usually
depicted as a man-made weapon
designed to defend japan from godzilla
but in all incarnations the character is
portrayed as a robotic clone with a vast
array of weaponry
and along with king ghidorah is
considered to be an arch enemy of
godzilla
although seen in only a couple of short
scenes in the trailer and tv spots
mechagodzilla still has raised the hype
level to over nine
thousand so let us look at the design of
this incarnation of the mecca
as per the images that were released and
the toys this robot is more robust than
the ones before it
it appears to be not streamlined or
refined in design
but displays a more rough and tough body
that
is more skeletal in appearance it looks
to be made more for practical reasons
than
pleasant looks as you can see literally
every moving part and joins
but as confirmed by plots it would be
controlled with the help of ghidorah's
jeans
and skull and it might be that the pilot
would be in some sort of a pacific rim
kind of drift
kind of style in order to be capable to
be at one with the mecca and make
streamlined movements
in the past mechagodzilla has displayed
a vast array of weapons and powers and
seemed to be
a walking super weapon system fitted
with the latest state-of-the-art
technology of that time
as well as futuristic weapons it is
equipped with an enormous arsenal
including eye beams an energy beam fight
from its chest
and missiles on its fingers knees and
toes which can also
function like dots it also has the
ability of flight
and as super mecha godzilla it can
combine with other weapon systems to
become a super version of itself
it also had the ability to generate a
shield it possessed
laser cannons from its eyes and a mega
bust away from its mouth
the mega buster ray in particular
appears to be
as powerful as godzilla's own atomic
breath but these are just
the first mechagodzilla and super mecha
godzilla kiryu
had even more powers like mazer cannons
and even laser
blades railguns drill weapons and an
absolute zero cannon
its ultimate power so what do you think
would be mecha godzilla's powers
and weapons in this upcoming movie would
it bring along with it
the powers from the showa or heisei era
or would it have
new ones that are specifically developed
to fight titanic's gojira here
in the monsterverse well for one there
will
definitely be big guns on the robots
like the ones that
appeared on striker eureka and the
jaeger from pacific rim
that can fire mega explosive shells and
as we have seen from one of the reveal
toy images
there would be shoulder launch missiles
in the dozens
so the staple weapons of humans would
most definitely be a part
of this mechanized titan as well and i'm
just guessing here as well as rail guns
with faster kinetic rounds and bombs
that end something with a lot of
fire this mecca would have to be built
from the strongest metal alloy
known to humanity and it wouldn't be
surprising that they would have to
develop a unique metal alloy for such
use
since we can see it walking past the
buildings in hong kong
and literally crushing them without even
slowing down
with extensive study of the big g and
his durability as well as powers
the mecca would have to have been
developed to possess an external armor
that can withstand every blow swipe and
atomic breath the g-man would throw at
it
and with such metal strength the four
limbs of mechagodzilla would also be
able to grab any titan including
godzilla himself
by the neck and even punch or bit slap
thick thighs
and hairy cheeks in hong kong but even
with all this
it wouldn't be a complete mechagodzilla
until we have a ranged attack
as we know mechagodzilla was always
taken down
by melee attacks from godzilla so we
still have two important powers that
would make this titan worthy of battling
the g-man
and that is his ranged attack his beam
or major weapon that can be used in the
same fashion as
the atomic breath without such an attack
this mechagodzilla would be forgotten in
time like mechagodzilla city
even ready player 1 showed mekha g
possessing a very hot flame
that can even melt the iron giant so
most of us would have to stick to the
staple and bring out a unique
legendary mechagodzilla atomic beam and
i'm just guessing here
i guess this would be red in color the
back spires and spines of mechagodzilla
would be able to stow
and eventually release it as a powerful
beam that can challenge godzilla's
attack in power and shock
value they could glow red before
shooting just like how godzilla's
and also plays gloves blue before
charging up and shooting the atomic
breath
one final weapon that it may have is the
emp
burst like that of the mutos back in
2014
this weapon is kind of like a shield
that can shut off any electronic device
that doesn't have backups
as we can see the huge differences in
power of the atomic breath
when compared between the 2014 and 2019
godzilla
this is due to the fact that the emp
burst of the meter was specifically
evolved in order to
lessen the intensity of the atomic
breath and to make the gojira species
more vulnerable to muto attacks
the back spines of mechagodzilla would
be used to store energy to release it
later as an emp
in order to weaken the king of the
monsters and remember that all these
weapons
if they can be used to defeat godzilla
then come on the other titans are also
vulnerable
to be killed by mechagodzilla and humans
and since guitar's dna and skull is
going to be infused with mecha godzilla
and it is rumored that the mecca would
go berserk and destroy everything around
it
then it might also have the gravity
beams
which were more to zero's powers but
again that's
a little bit unlikely so anyway we have
come to the end of this video
and just to recap mechagodzilla in
godzilla vs kong would have these powers
theoretically super durable alloy armor
heavy caliber guns rail guns missiles
massive arm claws a powerful ranged beam
attack
and most definitely an emp power so yes
subscribe to be a part of the mind cue
family and do hit that like button
as well as slap the notification bell
for regular updates on master news
and content right here on minecube take
care fam